so the rebranding has begun HBO Max is
going to become just max as it merges
with Discovery plus sort of not quite
it's very strange I will not understand
why they think dropping the HBO branding
is going to be good for them Max does
not have as much meaning HBO is a decent
name to attach to what the service was
given what used to be on it at any rate
and as far as the not quite merging with
Discovery plus thing well the thing is
Discovery plus is still going to exist
as its own Standalone thing that you can
get for cheaper than Max but Max will
also integrate a whole bunch of its
content
it seems very needless very finicky and
I have to wonder if the timing of the uh
Harry Potter TV show announcement uh was
partially to obscure this announcement
because there's nothing exciting about
this but there's plenty for people to
talk about with the Harry Potter show
not a lot of it's good but you know it's
a conversation